san sebastian's la concha bay and it's
famous promenade are popular with locals
and visitors alike the basque city is
also a paradise for food lovers along
with its gourmet restaurants the old
town's bars serve up regional
specialties like pinchos appetizers that
can be eaten warm or cold Elena
our sock is one of the few female chefs
to run a restaurant with three Michelin
stars together with her father Juan Mari
she heads the are sack restaurant its
facade may look unassuming yet the
establishment is known for its
innovative dishes and uncompromising
standards
Elena our Suk has been called the best
female chef on the planet when your
family is in the restaurant business
everything
always revolves around food I tried
kumquats for the first time when I was
seven and I ate truffles for the first
time at 7 or 8 I feel at home in the
kitchen vitami eskimo stallion Garza
the history of the restaurant is also
the history of the our Suk family who
have run it in the same building for
four generations after finishing her
studies in Lucerne Switzerland
Elena avisek worked in some of Europe's
top restaurants but her greatest
influence has been her father Juan Maria
Cusack who revolutionized Basque cuisine
in the 1970s their family's restaurant
also named Otto Suk has held three
Michelin stars since 1989
innovative and creative are words often
used to describe the are sucks cooking
style
cuisine with us groups but that doesn't
mean that we don't care about the
present current tastes as with
traditional dishes all our ingredients
are regional tradition and must uphold
beyond that it's a very creative cuisine
evolutionary or avant-garde cuisine that
at the same time remains very
down-to-earth
yes luckily no moodle a dealer the
restaurants upper floor houses the so
called laboratory here more than 900
different ingredients and aromas from
all corners of the globe are stored in a
climate-controlled robe every day the
team at the our stock tries out new
compositions resulting in the creation
of about 50 new dishes each year elena
Absa comes here when she's seeking
inspiration or to finish off a dish
she's creating those no matter if it's
like an archive for Romans you might
call it a bank for ideas a wide variety
of ingredients are stored here they're
collected and archived and then employed
when they're needed Basque cuisine is
strongly influenced by the region's
proximity to the sea fish and seafood
dishes are served up in many different
variations for her creations elena of
stock mainly uses regional produce
that's currently in season
the gourmet chef likes to select the
produce herself and chats with locals
Elena
our stock is well known in San Sebastian
after her trip to the market of SAC
likes to stop off at the ganbara the bar
in the old town is famous for its
pinchos
this here is a special local Pinchot
called shangri-la Donna's tiara or San
Sebastian crafts arts bar specializes in
them and they're really the best ones
around these spicy starters consist of a
tart filled with vegetable cream and
crabmeat and I'm going to use one now
for Elena out of stock cooking isn't
just a profession it's her calling the
mother of two often works in the
restaurant until midnight her life
revolves around the air suck and her
home city San Sebastian when tapas
I was born in San Sebastian and lived
here until I was 18 my family and my
roots are here
I've always liked son Sebastian I lived
abroad for six years but I wanted to
return to my roots
Yokogawa later I'm your life is no Elena
our Suk loves to experiment but still
remains faithful to her culinary roots
with her spirited cuisine
you